never say never divisive surgery but
nutella's here now with some ladies who
say yes please and right now me a little
bit more just a little bit more right
and it's easy for them to say that
because their husbands are the ones who
are holding the scalpels now I talked to
three women who are married to plastic
surgeons and beneath the surface not
always so pretty
I think marrying a plastic surgeon is
every girl's dream
their husbands do facelifts nose jobs I
live sin lipo sometimes even on their
own wives doctor Robert Ray has made
over his wife Haley what have you had
done yeah I've had well Botox fillers in
my lips Juvederm I've had my breasts
done my ears pinned back he does it and
you and you gotta brighten her
you know I hate it but she's the boss so
I'm limited to putting the implant
beneath her fat pad dr. Jason diamond
does a lot of face work but wife jessica
is staying away from his scalpel you
have had some things done I've had a few
things done and yes we underwent the
experience of me being a patient and
being the physician and I have to say it
was not it did not go smoothly it's like
the classic thing and when people say
you know you should not treat family
know like we understand why it did not
go well I don't look forward to ever
doing anything again
but for Jessica and dr. David Amron
there's nothing like the perk a free
work every now then I do a little Botox
on earth I've done a little bit of
subtle natural contouring to a cheek
area celebrity Plastic Surgeons of
Beverly Hills streaming on Netflix takes
us into the ORS and lavish lifestyles of
the doctors and their spouses dr. ray
also known as dr. 90210 and wife Haley
are having marital troubles and then
you're like running off to Palm Springs
when we see the show you guys are going
through a rough patch yeah but I wasn't
a monster you thought I was in a subject
we're going through the roughest part of
our marriage that we've ever done office
is the roughest we're actually talking
about divorce how did you come out the
other side then we had two options
either we divorce and go our separate
ways or we try to make this work I'm
angry at him all the time and resentful
so we decided to spend more time
together
and rebuild our marriage basically all
marriages are difficult is the last
lesson of life